Welcome to "English in a Minute",...
...where we teach you all about idioms in American English.
If I told you it was "raining cats and dogs" today,...
...I don't think you would see this little kitten falling from the sky.
But what would you see?
Let's watch and find out.
The rain is coming down so hard!
I know, it's raining cats and dogs today!
This is a very common expression in American English.
When you say that it's "raining cats and dogs" in a conversation,...
...it's another way to say that it's raining very hard or it's raining a lot.
You can use this expression anytime and everybody will understand you.
So, until the next time, stay dry!
And that's English in a Minute.